only 48 hours before the axe fell let's
go
this was Santa Javits last set of
interviews as Chancellor and was there a
hint there about the root cause of his
downfall it's absolutely right that we
have these fiscal rules because these
ensure that we keep public finances
under control but what it means is that
every time we think about your spending
more that we're going to have to think
very carefully about how we're gonna
finance it insiders say it was those
fiscal rules that attitude that spending
needed to be kept in check that put him
in the prime ministers sights ahead of
this reshuffle but his decision will
have consequences for all of us take a
view as to what the prime minister wants
to do and think to yourself they're
determined to try and carry those things
out and it reminds me yet again of the
first conservative administration that
mrs. Thatcher had and the phrase that
went around in those times was there is
no alternative and it sounds very much
like we're back to that again today
indeed this is hardly the first time an
occupant of number 10 has fallen to help
with their next-door neighbor Margaret
Thatcher went through three of them
crazy everyone remembers Brown versus
Blair if anything the surprising thing
is it's been so long since a Chancellor
did take a fall there is nothing new
about tensions between number 10 and
this place there's not just about
personalities it's about what they stand
for the Prime Minister is all about
splurging spending more and the Treasury
is all about keeping that spending in
check the big question now is whether
there is an economic shift whether this
power grab as one of Santa's David's
advisers described it to me makes a
serious difference to next month's
budget and the verdict from investors in
the market is yes in anticipation of
more spending and borrowing the interest
rate on UK government debt rose in the
hours after mr. Javid resigned not a
massive increase but it does mean
ironically that if the new chancellor
wants to borrow and spend more that debt
will be more expensive and more spending
and more borrowing may mean higher
inflation which could mean the next big
battle could be between Downing Street
and this place the Bank of England whose
new governor Andrew Bailey hasn't even
started yet
many prime ministers have attempted to
neutralize the Treasury many have hoped
that they would fulfill the destiny of
those words
on the letterbox of number 10 the big
question now is whether Boris Johnson
will succeed and what that means for the
rest of us at Conway Sky News